Voiceover: In the last video,
we saw how a bank would account for
fractional reserve lending
on its balance sheet,
and we did it with kind of
the conceptual understanding
that we've been talking about
fractional reserve
lending the entire time.
Someone deposits 100 million in reserves,
and 90 million of it gets lent out.
Of course, the offsetting liability
is that person could come at any time
and demand their money back.
When that 90 million of
currency is lent out,
the asset that it's
gotten in exchange for it
is 90 million worth of IOUs.
Now what I want to do in this video
is to clarify that this
is conceptually a good way
of thinking about
fractional reserve lending,
but what the bank can actually do
is slightly different than this.
They can actually create,
they can actually create the
they can expand both the
asset and the liability side
of their account
with just 10 million of reserves
to make this exact same thing happen.
One thing I do want to clarify.
These videos,
they are not an attempt
to either justify
fractional reserve lending
or in some way indict
fractional reserve lending.
It's really just to show
how it is accounted for.
You can take that debate on your own side,
whether you think it's worth doing or not,
fractional reserve lending.
Let's take the same example,
but now let's take an example where
so we're going to start the
same way that we started
in the previous video,
where I go buy,
I go buy $10 million worth of assets,
which are essentially the building
and things for my bank:
The buildings, the ATM,
the computer systems,
all of that.
I didn't take a loan to do it.
Let's just say I had that money,
so once again, I am
the owner of this bank,
and so I get 10 ...
I have all of the assets are owned by me,
so my owner's equity is $10 million,
is $10 million.
Now, in this example,
instead of getting $100
million of deposits
like we saw in the last one,
let's say that person A shows up
and gives us $10 million of deposits.
So they come,
and they deposit $10 million of currency,
so $10 million of federal reserve notes.
So write over there, $10 million,
and they can demand,
person A has a right to
demand their $10 million.
So this person, let's call them person B,
person B is one-tenth
as wealthy as person A,
so this is person B.
I'll just call it B's checking,
B's checking account.
Now, this is going to
seem very unintuitive,
what I'm about to do.
Because a bank only has to keep
of the amount of checkable
deposits they have,
only 10% of that has to be in reserves,
and we saw that over here,
instead of just only being able to lend
this money over here,
the bank could keep these reserves,
but then automatically
expand their checking,
their checkable deposits.
Let's say I go to this
bank right over here,
and I want a $50 million loan.
They're going to say,
"Okay, is he good for
the $50 million loan?
"Is he going to put it to good use?
"Is he likely to pay?"
Let's say they do decide
that Sal is good for the money.
what they can do,
they're going to lend me the money,
but they don't even have $50 of currency
to lend the money with.
What they will do is that they will create
a $50 million checking account for me.
So they will create a $50
million checking account,
so Sal's checking,
Sal's checking account,
and obviously, the bank
isn't in the business
of just giving away money.
What they will do is they'll
have an offsetting asset
that they will get from Sal,
which is an IOU from Sal.
So let me write it this way.
Loan to Sal would be an asset,
because in the future,
Sal's going to pay the bank.
We could call this "Loan to Sal"
or we could call this "IOU from Sal".
Let's say that Bill comes along,
I'm just making up names,
let's say Bill comes along,
and he wants to borrow another,
let's say, $40 million,
and the bank determines
that it's a good investment,
and so let me actually,
this is a,
just to make clear,
this was a $50 million,
this was a $50 million IOU from Sal,
and this is, I have 50 million worth of,
I guess I can write
checks up to $50 million
to go buy,
this was a $50 million loan,
so I can write checks against this now
to go and build my business or whatever,
or I could even take those checks,
and I could cash them out,
and of course the bank has to make sure
it has enough reserves.
It wouldn't want me to show up
and try to cash out more than $10 million.
If that started to happen,
they would have to go and borrow reserves
from either another bank
or, as a last resort,
from a central bank.
But let's just continue this
just to show that we can
actually end up having
identical balance sheets.
Let's say another businessman,
let's call him Bill,
comes along,
and let's say that he wants
to borrow $40 million.
So the exact same thing,
the bank decides to do it,
so what they will do
is they will lend Bill $40 million,
but once again,
they don't have that much in reserves.
They will essentially create
a checking account for Bill.
So, Bill's $40-million checking account,
and of course they don't want to just
hand him the money,
there's going to be an offsetting asset
they get from Bill,
which is essentially a 40-million IOU,
IOU from Bill.
Now you might say,
well, can't the bank just keep doing this?
Just creating, keep
getting more and more IOUs,
keep, kind of, creating money
because these checking
accounts really are money.
You're money-creating.
These people can now write checks
against the bank's ability
to cash those checks,
and the answer is
what's limiting this bank right over here
is the reserve requirements.
The bank can only,
the ratio of checkable
deposits to reserves
can only be 10 to 1,
or reserves have to be at least,
and this varies from country to country,
and this can change,
depending on the policies
of the federal reserve,
and that's one way they
have of controlling money,
although that's not the most typical way.
They have a reserve requirement here.
You have a 10%.
So, 10% of checkable deposits,
and this is true for
large banks in the US,
have to be held as reserves.
There has to be reserves for,
reserves for,
10% of checkable deposits.
That's what essentially keeps these banks
from doing this forever.
Now, this bank is all tapped out.
It's limited by the amount of loans it has
by its reserves.
I know it looks a little bit,
it looks a little bit suspect,
that they were able to essentially
create these checking
accounts out of scratch,
and only have,
they're essentially telling people,
"Look, there's 100
million that you can have
"on demand now to do whatever you need,"
when they only have 10 million in reserves
to back that up.
The rest of their assets
are IOUs from people,
but this is exactly what's happening
with the other conceptual version.
I guess the more traditional
conceptual reserve,
the more traditional
conceptual understanding
of fractional reserve lending.
You're telling someone
that they have 100 million
on demand,
but you're loaning 90 million of it out.
What they really have,
truly in the vault,
is $10 million.
So these two things,
these two things,
are actually functionally,
these two things are
completely equivalent,
and if you have a problem
with one of these,
if you feel like just
money is being created
by the bank,
it's actually happening in both cases.
In that case, you would be having trouble
with fractional reserve lending,
not just this idea right over here.